good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is a bright
beautiful sunny and exciting day here at
toast HQ it is Wednesday it is Sunday so
it's already like such a good day
because you know we're humpin the ones
that we love and you should too we're
humming the ones that we love in order
to get over the hump of the week and
it's really no better way to get through
it all so this is just like the middle
of a very exciting week for us and it's
also like the middle of the day usually
we start our day with the toast but we
pre recorded an episode before this a
guest segment with Lauren and Cameron
from love is blind it's up on our
YouTube right now it'll be at the end of
this podcast episode and if you've seen
the YouTube video and you want the whole
interview headed over to the podcast
they were just so that they have to
pre-record because they're so busy there
to be news they're doing everything
around town and I'm so glad they're
getting like the press and the respect
that they deserve they were on watch
trap inside last night and I watched it
they were here they were so lovely they
answered all of our questions they that
couldn't stop touching each other we
here's the thing we live in a free
country for sure but we have absolutely
no choice but to respect and stand the
hell out of the Hamiltons
and that's all I'll say on that 100%
we've a very exciting we would have
woken up that early for anyone else
honestly I really don't like to
pre-record because to be honest like the
fun of our show is the live element and
every now and then we do prerecorded
because the guests can't make it and we
would do anything to have them like Reza
we've never been able to have him and he
was only able to comment like 4 o'clock
on a random day and Lauren and Cameron
at the same they made time for us early
in their day which was so nice and their
special that's all I'll say
they're so special I hope you guys enjoy
the interview we asked every single
question that me ever had about love is
blind and they were open books like us
before them we weren't asking like the
typical questions we were asking like
the logistics like where did you sleep
the [ __ ] cups you guys really all we
needed to know because everything else I
feel like I could make sense of in one
way or another but I just didn't
understand those cups because the
spoiler alert the answer is it's a
continuity thing for television but
there are so many reality TV shows and
that's never been done before
so when Margot and I went to visit it's
not even reality TV when me and Margo
went to go visit the blueblood set we
got to see one of the family dinner
scenes and they all have glasses of wine
and literally after each take they would
do a ten-second take people would come
in and measure the cups it's like such
an ordeal that actually I can't believe
people haven't done this before it's
genius
I get really distracted a lot of the
times on reality TV booth when I see
someone's eye hairs in front and then
the hair came back and the cup is pulled
in the cup is empty cuz then I know like
she said this one thing at the end of
the conversation because her glass is
empty but you're making it seem like
it's the beginning yeah so we won't
spoil any more of the interview it'll be
at the end of this podcast episode and
it's already up on our YouTube channel
so go check it out they were the
snatchler oh they have a stylist ahead
glam team like they are snatched to the
gods to the gods other than that it's
already been a great show so far and we
have a rest of the great show for you
but today's episode honestly like the
only thing that anyone is really talking
about well two things one praying for
our nashville toaster is terrible oh my
god so terrible what happened and I just
have to come I mean the toasters would
really do never cease to amaze me but
there's already like a full Google Doc
being put together people in need people
who have supplies people who are looking
for supplies people are looking who are
looking for places to stay so if you're
in Nashville and you listen to this
podcast please join the Nashville
toasters because there's a whole
community like a people ready to help so
I mean that's horrible it's been amazing
we're thinking of all you guys down
there but also coronavirus is just like
taking this country also i know we don't
talk about it here but also super
tuesday like is a big deal okay I guess
like three major things so I guess like
the celeb news has been kind of quiet
but coronavirus is here welcome to New
York it's been waiting for you three
cases we've got some like human-interest
celeb versions of coronavirus stories
for you guys today because that's what's
going on in the world we also going to
recap Vanderpump rules and we're gonna
do a dear toaster segment which we
haven't done in a while
as a reminder dear toasters is our
advice segment if you're ever looking
for advice email us your toasters at
gmail.com we always keep it anonymous so
you don't to worry about any of that the
more interesting the better if we've
been skipping to your toasters it's just
for lack of good submissions because I
just can't do any more about like my
friends being mean to me like I want
more you know something different
I want more interesting okay make me
think I want more my bosses hiding water
bottles in the basement of our office
you want it to be something to think
about that's pretty much what I'm saying
thank you Jackie okay well I guess
without further ado it's time for the
Fast Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's true Jackie and you know I
love you very very much and I really
respect you like of all the things thank
you like of all the
things I feel about you like I think the
number one thing is that I have respect
for you like you're very smart
businesswoman and take there's a but
coming
no there's nothing but necessarily I
just don't want to step on your chosen
make it come off like I'm being
disrespectful because they know you have
a job to do and I know that you have to
tell us the fast five stories and I'm
gonna let you finish I swear but you
know I have a job to do and that job
requires being open and honest with my
audience
yeah and that openness is in the form of
me letting everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by embark
whether you have a new dog or an old
friend and embark breed and health test
is the key to unlocking your dog's
unique breed mix and genetically
informed health needs so you can help
your pup live its healthiest happiest
life I know it's very sad um I recently
found out that dogs don't live forever
and that's been really difficult and
heartbreaking for me but through the
help of embark I'm gonna keep vo the
healthiest and strongest dog so we can
live lion Hara a hundred years yeah I
should die before Theo well oh my god
Sam red get to know your pup every year
millions of dogs are rescued from
shelters and while we know we love them
there's a lot that we don't know about
them with an embark DNA test kit you can
finally have all the answers you need
next time someone stops you with a how
cute what kind of dog is that you can
discover tons of things about your dog
from both health to breed information I
did it for Theo the process was so easy
they send you a box with a little q-tip
swab you swab Theo's cheek pouches he
was trying to eat the q-tip you throw
the q-tip back in the in the little tube
send the tube in the Box they gave you a
prepaid label and then like maybe two
weeks later I got a text message that my
results were and I totally forgot about
it it was such like a nice surprise and
I basically found out that Theo is 100
percent perfect that's what the thing
said yeah
also it's cool because they give you all
this information and then you're able to
write a little rap about your pups and
it goes a little something like this he
just took a DNA test
turns out he's a hundred percent Russian
even when he's fleeing countries yeah
he's got health problems that's a puppy
in him
bling-bling then he saw them without the
doctor and you could have had a bad tags
noncommittal helped you with your
welfare just a little you still hold me
down
now I'm holding you back and that's the
sound of his wolf penis leading the pack
deadly gotta be but let me just tell you
that over fifty percent of dogs are
either at risk of a or a carrier of
genetic diseases but the embark panel of
test screens for over 170 genetic
diseases which can be present in many
breeds whether it's mixed breed or a
pure breed which Theo is embark is the
only research grade dog DNA test kit on
the market it is more than twice as
precise as any other dog DNA test kit on
the market this is because their
scientists look at over 200,000 genetic
markers and can make scientific
discoveries that help all dogs live
longer healthier lives it's the best in
class dog DNA test kit the number one
highest rated by customers developed by
PhDs and veterinarians and is the most
breed it is most accurate breed
identification on the market with more
than twice as precise as the next
competitor embark has an exclusive offer
that you can't get anywhere else but the
chose so if you have a dog or you know
someone has a dog it's a great gift for
like a crazy dog for the crazy dog mom
in your life go to embark vet dot-com
now and use the promo code toast to save
15% off your dog DNA test kit that's
EMBA RK v ET comm with the promo code
toast to save 15% off your dog DNA test
kit Wow thank you for sharing that with
us we appreciate your openness and your
honesty yeah that's the thing I've never
not branded myself as being open and
honest with my audience like I tried to
get lip fillers and not tell them and
they knew yeah but you also didn't try
to not tell them no I just wanted to do
n e1e pible of lining something to
yourself I just wanted to see I got them
I was actually wearing this sweater
which is so funny um I got them and then
I didn't say anything the next day I
want to see if anyone noticed and I got
1 million DMS I was never gonna lie I
was just genuinely curious if there was
like a huge difference
totally sign on write a song about your
dog pretty much okay let's get right
into it because um Anna Wintour is among
the top fashion editors in
self-quarantine after returning from
Milan sure go as we know there's over
10,000 positive cases of corona virus in
Italy and you know fashions elite has
just returned from Milan you know what's
so crazy really quickly is that I feel
like Emily's like to us the first
country that's like so plagued by it but
I forget that it really started in China
but they like weren't telling us
anything about it yeah it started in
China in December and we've been talking
about it
traveling for about a month now I
remember the first time we talked about
it was in a January I think was the same
episode when Kobe had passed away um and
it's been slowly making its way over
there had been cases in Washington as
yesterday there were three cases in New
York yeah and so now it is at our front
door and it's gonna be really crazy to
see like how you know how'd it go away
yeah and how it's gonna cycle out a lot
of experts are saying that you know come
spring the virus won't be able to live
anymore it's kind of similar to the flu
and it can only thrive in hopefully
climates but maybe they don't know we
don't know is unprecedented
it's unprecedented so so because by the
way so many people went to Milan Fashion
Week yeah so the world's leading
fashionistas who traveled to Milan for
the fashion shows including Anna Wintour
el editor-in-chief Nina Garcia and
InStyle editor-in-chief Laura brown are
all in self-imposed quarantine since
they returned from the corona virus
infected country so let me get this
straight
Anna Wintour and the inter Garcia put
themselves in self-imposed quarantine
and they get written up in the news but
like I put myself in self-imposed
quarantine like almost every day you're
just like oh please and no one cares
yeah Anna Wintour is working from home
like okay so are we yeah but she think
she's special nobody know and I think
interesting it's these people for
they're obviously not showing any signs
of coronavirus but they were near it
yeah so I respect that like people who
are just so reckless about this and like
travel and then they come back and like
lick their hands and shake everyone's
hands like that to me that's so
irresponsible like I really feel like
this should be at the forefront of
people's minds and to me this is setting
a great example yes and it's very
precious at the forefront of people's
minds but it is very interesting how
like you know this disease and culture
and fashion it's just it's how it all
Rhona versus i literally melting
everything like politics fashion like
everyone is subjected to this no one no
matter how rich or poor famous you are
like Republican or Democrat like you
could get coronavirus today yes and
honestly there's nothing very humbling
about that
I also saw an interesting story that
Apple co-founder Steve Wozniak suggests
that he might have been coronavirus
patient zero because he said and he's
like kind of kidding but not he enjoy
marry him and his wife like got what
they called the worst flu of their lives
after visiting Southeast Asia
oh my god and he post he tweeted on
Monday a video of Janet scoff his wife
and he thinks that they might have been
patients here in the US and what they
didn't know was that they were fighting
off coronavirus if I like had this
information that me and my wife travel
to China I got sick and then like
literally the next day like everyone in
America was sick from a disease from
China like I would shut the [ __ ] up like
I would not tell anyone why I feel like
blasting this from the rooftops it's not
his fault
it's a little embarrassing yeah I mean
it's unclear but that's crazy to think
about I know I've just like as of last
night it becomes so hyper aware of this
and there's two types of mentalities
going on when people are talking about
coronavirus either people are like
really involved very invested maybe a
little paranoid but like stocking up on
canned foods and like getting so much
extra soap and Purell and then there's
people who are like the flu kills
millions of people a year like why are
we talking about that and coronavirus is
not a big deal like everyone's making it
a big job people are like the media is
causing hysteria I just agree I don't
know what the right thing is but I don't
think people are hysterical at all no I
know just like all talking about it in
casual conversations dinner parties but
like everyone's walking around without a
care in the world I like to me I think
this week is when like I don't think I'm
gonna I mean it's great to have an
excuse not to work out but I think the
gym is like a hotbed of where you could
get coronavirus so I think I'll just
have to be staying home you know I'm
really making a concerted effort not to
go to like super packed places even
though I am going to the Celine Dion
concert tomorrow night and that's just
like I would get coronavirus for that
because I've never seen her before and
it's gonna be like a magical moment so
she's worth it she's worth it I'm going
as well and I've already made the
decision to like I want to dress up for
the concert obviously because she
deserves that and so I think I'm gonna
go with like an opera glove look which
is very corona chic so I owe it's so
functional but also fabulous yeah so I
think if you post an Instagram will you
make [ __ ] caption functional but
fabulous or like coronavirus but make it
fashion okay now like we're lame yes for
sure yeah that's I hadn't worked chopped
at yet but I also need to find a pair of
our gloves that aren't the lime-green
ones that I have for Vegas yeah I think
that's probably for the best but also
I'm just like people who are like you're
causing hysteria like that mentality is
really bothering me like I do think we
should be taking this seriously
and better to be too scared and too
prepared or to nuts then not give a [ __ ]
and then end up like running out of
Purell and not being able to buy
anything on Amazon which is what is
happening to me yes which leads me to
our next story to CNN business is
reporting that Americans are panic
shopping for hand sanitizer and face
masks and soap Americans across the
country are stocking up on hand
sanitizer cleaning wipes toilet paper
and other products to prepare for the
spread of coronavirus long lines at
stores in panic buying on cleaning
products throughout the country are
stretching American retailers ability to
keep up with demand
shoppers are posting pictures on social
media of lines sneaking around Costco
and empty shells and sanitizers at CVS
Walgreens and other drugstores also on
Amazon that's what's so crazy it's like
okay I could understand one store
running out of sanitizer but for all of
Amazon sellers to be completely
unavailable I went on last night because
I was watching watch what happens live
and Andy said that there's actually a
hand soap shortage or like we're at an
all-time low so I'm like damn you know I
have like two bottles of soap look let
me get some more and I ordered like
antibacterial on Amazon and then I was
like let me get some hand sanitizer too
and I figured maybe Purell would be like
low on stock but I could get like
generic Target brand Target was sold out
Amazon was completely sold out it was
freaky like that was giving me like
zombie apocalypse vibes totally my hands
are so dry from washing them good silly
murderously but I also have like just a
huge advocate for hand washing and I
just can't stress it enough and I've
been washing my hands with Dawn dish
soap which is I think like the strongest
there is
oh that's pretty sure which is so bad
for like the quality of my hands but I
don't care cuz as of now knock on wood I
don't have coronavirus yeah but it's
it's here in New York you know I don't
think she's she's going away anytime
she's getting bigger by the day yeah so
take the necessary precautions um and
you know it's always just there's always
you never need a great excuse to not
leave your house right and don't like
turn your life upside down but like take
it seriously yes and don't make fun of
people who are like stocking up on soap
because we're scared and we're just
doing what we can to make us feel better
I'm accelerating I have enough food yeah
I've seen him at that time look I didn't
with a bunch of my girlfriends and
Margot was like do you guys like stock
up on like canned foods and she went
what you call it preserve preservatives
not things without things with
preservatives but things that can be
preserved yes and I was like no and she
was like oh I stocked up I'm like I'm
like you did well you have your duty
that's what I said I actually have to
Judy's by the way not that like it's
good or anything but this is probably
really good for Judy business yeah I
fits great for micro business knowing
that I have a genie too it's definitely
like a really good safety net I feel not
that scared
mm-hmm okay next story a little fashion
meets podcasting news love to see it
Diane von Furstenberg is launching a
podcast with Spotify huh the show will
be called in charge with DVF guests
include Kris Jenner Priyanka Chopra and
Karlie Kloss I love this I love you know
I love when the podcasting world it's
bigger and more legitimate that's all I
love this first modify I love this for
DVF I think that the world could use
more and more of her wisdom ever since
her show house of DVF which you love was
so rudely canceled just after Hanna Beth
won the ambassador position she never
even got to serve on the UN of DVF um I
love this more gif content I just like
that podcasting is becoming like a more
and more serious format like the fact
that Lauren and Cameron are like in New
York doing press and they're doing
mostly TV but they made a stop by our
podcast and I'm sure they're doing one
or two others like that is just a great
moment for podcasting and so is this DVF
is so fabulous and she's one of the
unique people who has like a connection
in terms of guests to like the biggest
celebrities the biggest people in
fashion
Royals like she is such a well-connected
woman that I feel like we're gonna hear
from people who would never do podcast
like Kris Jenner has she ever been on a
podcast before I do not think so they
must been on - I'm sure Kris Jenner has
done like a business one you know I
don't know I feel like it's gonna be
fabulous
wait also we didn't really get to
debrief Daymond John oh I know but we
did record him before the show yesterday
so me kind of debriefed on the show but
I also like because his youtube comment
and I was like maybe he's still
listening so he was like so engage with
us on social media like sharing
everything I posted and like tagging me
was so nice but the second most Hollow
chart because he's in tune with what's
nests in the value of a couple
influencers by the way like him
remembering us in the Bahamas dead dead
but also like thoroughly embarrassed and
I also was getting the vibe that like
yes we saw him in the elevator but he
must have seen us elsewhere you know
he'll remember the elevator he just
remembered the nutjobs running yeah in
the hotel writing by the pool ready in
the beach I'm sure he was just like she
scored yeah but I think wearing the
Blazers yesterday like balanced it out
and I'm sure he was like get you a girl
who could do both yeah and then you
don't like our operation we work hard
work hard play hard what's the
point of working so hard to not be able
to go to the Bahamas with your best
friends and rave your face off Jackie
right absolutely no point let me
actually right now we actually spoke
about this on Marco Joseph's podcast
which we recorded it's gonna be up in a
few weeks but speaking of Margaret
Joseph's podcast launched today so the
first episode is up she's basically the
gasps you're getting to know a lot about
her her journey on Housewives her
journey in her business she's just so
funny I'm it's available on Spotify
iTunes all the places you can listen to
podcasts but we just recorded an episode
for her podcast that'll be up soon and
we were talking so much about it cuz you
and her both don't drink but it was more
about like celebrating not so much
drinking that's like really what's the
point like I work hard so that I can
like black out you know and I feel
entitled to that privilege yeah for me
it's like I work hard for the vacations
yeah you know because that to me is what
life's all about Kylie it's lovely right
now oh my god Bahamas
yes confirmed it's the Bahamas you know
page six down the head thought it was
Turks and Caicos dollars and I was
watching I love this Kendall's there
with her from home
I think kinda like needs more of those
like she works so hard she wants too
hard sometimes her work and her play is
kind of the same like her friends are
models blah blah blah and so I'm happy
for her that she's just in the Bahamas
watching The Bachelor with Kylie who was
getting an IV and I I'm assuming it's
because she was hungover deadbeats like
love to be invited we have no choice yes
it's a free country like you said we
have no choice but to stand it's a free
country allegedly but okay next story is
really crazy Susan is it the story
that's brought to you by frame bridge
cuz that does sound crazy mmm I think it
is I do think Mike do you think that it
is okay you let me know because you know
like I said I have that tell me more and
then I'll let you know we've got to tell
you guys that about amazing new company
called frame bridge they make it
ridiculously easy and affordable to
custom frame your favorite things from
art prints and posters to the tribal
photos sitting on your phone here's how
it works just go to frame bridge comm
and upload your own photo or they'll
send you packaging to safely mail a
physical photo you could preview your
item online into dozens of frames
choose your favorite or get free
recommendations from their talented
designers the experts of frame bridge
will custom frame your item and deliver
your finished piece directly to your
door ready to hang instead of the
hundreds you'd pay at a framing store so
true their prices start at $39 and all
shipping is free plus our listeners will
get 15% off their first order at frame
bridge comm when they use our code toast
framing is literally like
the business of framing is my cross to
bear and whenever I have something that
I want to frame whether it's a personal
picture sometimes I like buy art the
framing sometimes cost more than the
poster like it's crazy and the fact that
like a company like this hasn't existed
before is shocking but frame bridge is
really everything of the sort especially
if you're in our HD Steen being group
and you love like a framed moment check
it out you'll have a gallery wall yeah I
have a picture in my bedroom that's a
framed photo of me that Zack took and
then he got it framed from frame baked
frame bridge and it was really like the
perfect gift and also the perfect art in
our apartment agreed because who better
than you to decorate your own walls of
course
get started today frame your photos or
send someone the perfect gift go to
frame bridge calm and use the promo code
toast to save an additional 15% off your
first order go to frame bridge calm
promo code toast frame bridge calm promo
code toast thank you I'm so sorry to
have interrupted you on your own show
sign on get the hassle of framing done
for you like in a way sign on and frame
it up and in a way that's you know very
2020 okay I mean like no one has time to
be carrying their their art to the
framer okay and I actually I had a
really tumultuous thing happened to my
frame work do you know about the story
no I actually had it too much just a
couple tumultuous priming experiences
like I went to one framer once and like
I got totally screwed and like the frame
was [ __ ] no I had a personal me too with
a framer we do a different framer than
the first one
no wonder what yours is okay I was like
so crazy no no mines I bet you - crazy
what's yours
no I don't even like what if he's
watching I can't no he's not so I used
to go to this frame like all the time
because I got my diploma frame and then
I was like my art from me and then it's
an apartment I even though I moved I
kept going to the streamer cuz he really
has great prices and he was so lovely
and you know it takes a long time when
they're like paying and checking out he
was just like asking me so much about
what I do which I really hate with
people to do so I was like explaining
like the Instagram girl no job and then
like he was just obsessed and was like
oh my god I would love to like pick your
brain and I was like yeah sure sure and
I just like left and I didn't realize he
had my phone number because like for the
pickup right so we call me and I'm like
oh hi like is my frame right he's like
now mics why the [ __ ] are you calling
he's like I would love to like take you
out for pizza and like talk to you I'm
like oh yeah there's something about
pizza and I'm like I'm literally running
into anything but I'll call you right
back and of course I didn't litter he
called me almost every day
we can I kept forgetting because I have
the number saved I kept forgetting and
picking up
I mean Libby was just like asking me out
on it like not a date but like add a
date to let go shot like chatting about
marketing and I just wanted to die and I
like had to pick up the frame I made Ben
go and I never went back again Wow
mine I think is actually that's pretty
bad but I think I know which room you
were talking about and that was the one
I had the first experience with where
the framing was just not even on point
um and I'll tell you the second one
later because it was just like it's too
recent that's so weird that's the thing
thank God for frame bridge is the moral
of the story okay
next story is a little publishing drama
and before I get into it I want to let
you know new episode of the redheads is
coming out tomorrow and I am so excited
make sure you read the book subscribe to
the redheads head over there follow us
on Instagram it's just so much fun the
book was such an easy read I read it in
two days so you can even start it today
and listen tomorrow like I swear but
Ronan Farrow cannot in good conscience
work with his publisher anymore after it
bought Woody Allen's book there's so
much drama so you know Ronan Farrow
wrote catch and kill he won the Pulitzer
Prize for public service in 2018 for
helping break the Harvey Weinstein
scandal he is also like a son of Woody
Allen oh right I forgot that they're
related he's Mia Farrow's son and Mia
Farrow was married to Woody Allen yeah
and he's also Dylan Pharaoh's brother
okay so he posted to his Twitter I was
disappointed to learn through press
reports that hatchet my publisher
acquired Woody Allen's memoir after
other major publishers refused to do so
and concealed the decision from me and
its own employees while we were working
on catch and kill a book about how
powerful men including Willy Woody Allen
avoid accountability for sexual abuse
hatchet did not fact check the Woody
Allen book my sister Dylan has never
been contacted to respond to any denial
or mischaracterization of the abuse she
suffered at the hands of Woody Allen a
credible allegation maintained for
almost three decades backed up by
contemporaneous accounts and evidence
it's wildly unprofessional
unprofessional and multiple obvious
directions for hatchet to behave this
way and love a little publishing drama
is this an episode of younger this is
such publishing drama but I find it to
be really interesting that people are
not taking what he Allen's memoir that
was the most interesting thing because
to me Woody Allen has like not been
cancelled but they are take like they
nobody
but multiple people like turned it down
like that I find to be shocking yeah I I
feel like I started reading catch and
kill and it's really good it's just
really dumb and so I needed to like
spread it out
I feel like Woody Allen's memoir is
gonna be really good I think it's he's
gonna say a lot of stuff oh really I
don't think that they would decide to
publish it unless it was juicy if' yeah
with like a lot of different opinions
and I've loosely followed all of the
drama around Woody Allen but it's like I
barely follow his movies so I don't I'm
not familiar with all of the allegations
no but all I'm familiar with was that he
married his stepdaughter and that's
[ __ ] weird and whether it's illegal or
unethical it's up to you we can all
agree whether you like Woody Allen or
not it's [ __ ] weird
yeah but the he's very polarizing
because some people have like totally
cancelled him and other people who are
fans of his or have even worked Scarlett
Johansson refuses to cancel again by him
so it's not so cut it's not black and
white it's not so black and white yet
but I feel like his memoir is gonna help
wrote a whole nother narrative in yeah I
know a little different perspective that
it's gonna be interesting yeah I don't
like care enough about him to really
like come out for him like whether in
defense or in taking him down like I
really don't know enough about it like
he's definitely weird and has weird
tendencies like marrying your
stepdaughter even though you're not
related there's something weird to it
similar to how it was a little weird how
Cher and her brother ended up together
at the end of clueless yes they weren't
related but you have the same dad
technically like at one at one point
like and it's weird it's weird and now
it talks about it and no one's really
talking about they say all the things
Woody Allen did is weird to me the
weirdest thing he did is marrying his
stepdaughter yeah no I think that's
that's among the things that are weird
to people okay but I don't know it's
like we were shipping Daenerys and Jon
Snow okay that was like a hypothetical
medieval we were out there's shipping
a big [ __ ] ship yeah no a cruise ship
that got contained for coronavirus I had
to stay at the port for two weeks but we
were still on the ship pardon Oh anyways
I might actually just read the book so
that I have some some thoughts yeah I
just I keep up with so many celebrities
so many controversies so many scandals
like my plate is literally and
figuratively so full I did not my plate
I just can't give a [ __ ] about what he
Alan literally on the
Jaggi said i feel like if i say the
story like people don't think it's funny
but Jackie made me laugh probably the
hardest I've ever laughed like in the
last year on the plane because we were
sitting in business class and like each
seat is only two in a row me and Jack
and we're sitting next to each other and
each seat has like a little area for you
like leave your [ __ ]
and I looked over at Jackie's table and
it honestly looked so manly and I was
like all of his stuff like it's you look
like it looks like Zak what your husband
is sitting in this chair because he's
like obsessed with like phones and
gadgets and air pods and Jackie had like
her iPad in her hair pods in like her
little Kindle and her Kindle stand it
was just like a boy's table like mine
had like and also the Delta big
headphones were on the table too making
it all look very man literally looked
like you worked here I could be the
president of the a/v Club like with all
your catches and I literally said to him
like this is so weird like you literally
look like a man like if I just saw the
side table I would think that you were
your husband but I felt as it was like
the head from somewhere bringing me down
so I was like these aren't my headphones
that's not my plate still makes me laugh
such a great reference a nod to Real
Housewives of Orange County Shannon
beador not her finest moment but it
really made me laugh yeah not to be
there you did be misty yeah big and
final story is it
no but it's a little food news a little
food news a little a little food news
okay
because chick-fil-a has announced that
fish will be offered at select
restaurants for a limited time
disgusting please for all the been
vegetarians very excited I've never
eaten that chick-fil-a before oh now I
can get that give me that chick fillet a
fish or give me that no clothes on
Sunday you're my fish fillet closed on
Sunday your matches for leg-hold the
selfies remember when we performed in
unreleased Kanye West song on this show
at the request of Kanye and his team yes
I do I just think like if you're a new
toaster here like you just started
listening to the show hi welcome I just
I don't think that should be something
that's ever gonna be forgotten but it's
like if you go and watch it now for the
first time you'll be like oh they're
performing closed on Sunday we were in
it when you are sent sheet music through
song that you've never heard the night
before and but the song's about to come
out in two days but then the album was
delayed anyway no that time it actually
came out
but it came out later in the day
whenever we were sitting at lunch before
we email before we interviewed the show
um so at the time it was like is this a
Kanye West yeah we weren't sure if we
were being pranked yeah and I think that
everyone was just like right there with
us like total it's gonna be on the album
the kinda questions was real um the
seasonal chick-fil-a fish sandwich is
back at select restaurants during the
late winter and early spring as in years
past Cod will be the catch of the day
this sounds so delicious and I'm so
hungry and I just absolutely love and
actually so hungry right now like I
guess we've done pop at the crack of
dawn yeah I love when fast food chains
are just saying more inclusive to those
of us who don't eat meat and you know
what now
that I am Joaquin Phoenix tan and I'm
just like transitioning to more of a
plant-based diet mmm I guess this isn't
considered plant base Italy base yet um
but it's not land based yep so that's
good um I know vegan chick-fil-a a few
times and every time I talk about
chick-fil-a it's like the most
controversial thing ever because to me
it's just like an average Raising Cane's
like it's just a fast food like it's not
anything crazy but I saw really
interesting
tik-tok last night because what
chick-fil-a is really really known for
is obviously like their food but more so
their sauces and there's a sauce
somebody put together that the yellow
sauce like people love to dip their
fries and I don't know what it's called
is actually like bottled and sold by
like another company at the grocery
store so like they did this whole taste
test and it was exactly the same so if
you [ __ ] with chick-fil-a go find that
tic toc cuz you can buy the chick-fil-a
sauce it's just like a Heinz good for
them yeah that sounds like a win for
everyone and you know what I appreciate
that because sometimes when it comes in
a battle you don't need to make your own
ketchup sir Kensington you just don't
perfect formula and ketchup recently
that was [ __ ] disgust
at the four seasons in Beverly Hills we
had drinks with your friend Brookman and
want my friend to be like your friend
and she ordered sliders and we got
ketchup on the side and the ketchup for
the cheese this ketchups it was soup it
was discussing ketchup is really like
it's weird because it exists everywhere
in the perfect formula like Heinz is
everything but it's so easy to [ __ ] up
yeah even though like we have the
perfect formula bottled and distributed
globally yeah that's why it's hard for
me to travel abroad they don't have good
ketchup and they don't have Diet Coke in
Europe yeah Coke Zero it is just not the
same you know maybe like it's better cuz
it's better for you I would rather die
of too much Diet Coke
ever just be like drinking coke zero
people think that Coke Zero is better
because it tastes like regular coke but
I don't like the taste of regular hook I
like that
aspartame flavor from the diet coke
we're him so if I'm looking to have a
diet coke I don't want to have a coke
we're gonna recap inner pump roles but
we're gonna take a break because there's
a siren
we're back we're back let's talk about
Vanderpump rules we had like kind of a
boring episode before the wedding they
just got to Kentucky I'm so [ __ ]
excited for this wedding episode because
I just like I'm gonna watch with a
microscope to see if me and my shiny
dress are anywhere in the background I
just know like Ben is gonna find himself
to like being the center of a storyline
or something like I but you know what's
really interesting is I saw that um they
did they're like editing it really that
cuz that rehearsal wasn't when they
landed because I remember like being
there and I think it was on Saturday
whatever they just like chopped it up a
little bit but um what happened before
that Tom obviously got himself invited
to the wedding he made an apology after
the text message was not sufficient for
Jax and even after he apologized in
person we thought all was good and Jax
was like I'm a hundred percent not over
what happened I'm just doing this to
like make everyone shut up which I
literally laughed out loud so hard we
like we're like it's great harmony and
then boom yeah I I'm glad that that it
all worked out I think Jax is like
harping on a little too much but I also
think that maybe there were things that
happen like in the past year that it's
just like Sanibel isn't his close friend
anymore I don't think it was this one
thing because agree but I do think for
the sake of the group in the show like
he wants it the wedding to not be about
the fact that Tom's animals yeah but
like when they were rehearsing and they
like wanted him to be the second in
command like that was so awkward and
it's completely true like Tom seeing of
all I don't think they're super close
right yeah I think a lot of what this
whole argument had to deal with was not
them one incident obviously that was the
straw that broke the camel's back but it
really seems like they've been fighting
a lot and they're just like not in the
place that they used to be in anymore
they're so different it's kind of like
Kristen and the girls like yeah it's
times change friendships change
especially when you throw Fame and they
show into the mix and everyone's and new
relationships and people go their
separate ways yes so I think that
they're just like not close anymore so
okay so we just let him come for the
sake of the group but then it's like
alright I actually don't want you
standing next to me like this is
important and I understood why he got
like a little frustrated I totally agree
the castle was so beautiful my God's so
beautiful that really is like a dream
venue than you I love the rooms I love
the setup like that is everything of the
sort to me I love the fact that it's
like literally on the side of the
highway like in a cornfield as James
kind of yelled it but that's like
literally even like my dream wedding
don't you married like on a farm in a
castle it was beautiful but I had a
feeling I'm like I'm sure if I went
upstairs into other rooms like they
would be a dump but they were like five
star realness
so nice it was really really beautiful
and it was like on the side of the
highway but like the driveway it was
easy to get to the driveway was so long
that you couldn't hear the highway I'm
not worried about the highway you know
like I've been to outdoor weddings where
you could literally hear a truck and
like that's bad yeah or like a podcast
where you can hear a siren oh my god
it's so [ __ ] away James and Markel
we're not at the wedding and they didn't
even make it like a a point to play okay
like Peter's not gonna invite James to
his birthday because Jax is there in
what world with Jackson focus on James
to his wedding but I think in the past
like James would have like tried to get
himself invited yes but that's only
because the show were revolved around
the oh geez yeah of the group whereas
now James and Mark Heller and the
younger set Max and Dana and Charli XCX
they were not there either so I don't
him it's not like a firing you know it
used to be if you're not at the big
event of the season what are you doing
on this show right then order to
maintain your relevancy now that we have
two different shows yeah he's on you
know the new generation I just so like
not interested in the storyline about
Raquel and James like to me they've
always been so toxic I wasn't interested
in it until James was on watch what
happened yeah last night and said that
he is nine months sober and I am so
proud of him and I believe him like he's
said that before but he's never said
nine months but he's just said that like
he's he's like Ramona Singer I'm gonna
change him and change and then never
actually does but I saw like a real like
difference in him last night me too and
I think him and Raquel are you know
there's a lid for every pot yeah um and
the issues in their relationship stem
from when he's drunk which means that he
can no longer drink and he is no longer
drinking and as long as he's making
those positive changes and continues to
do that we have to support him of course
but like I just can't imagine even if
someone does change like ever like
staying with someone who called me a
[ __ ] oh I mean I'm not the kind of
woman that could do that no but she
she's able to so it's crazy it's crazy
and I still don't come down his behavior
but if he hadn't been on my diamonds
last night I would be like literally
talking so much [ __ ] today but I was
just really impressed that you know
people so many times they're like okay
this will be the time I changed okay I
really yeah this time and he really
meant at that time and that's all that
we can ask from people is to evolve and
changing gremlin Andy asked him if he
was going to be invited to Randall and
Lala's wedding and he said yes and he
was so excited like I really felt like
that was a great moment for him and I
think that he was like really proud of
himself forgetting
my dad totally and I think the
friendship between him and Lala is it's
so complex and I love when their friends
in the fact that they're both sober I
think it's like a really healthy
foundation and I think that when James
is in a bad spot like with himself he's
in a bad spot with Lala because she
won't be like surrounded by that
toxicity because she's in such a good
place so when he's sober and when he's
good and he's doing really well that's
when their friendship can mend it's like
his his relationship with himself is
parallel to the relationship he has with
Lala yes it's really quite beautiful and
there was a bunch of loser on loser
crime with like the newbies and scheana
the whole Charlie Brett scheana thing
honestly I didn't really like Charlie
before but I absolutely hate her now
that she like turned that whole
conversation about scheana onto bread
yeah like it was just like she was
talking [ __ ] about you and you're mad at
Brett for telling me the whole thing was
so sharing I was I was just like on Team
Brett these two can go like and by the
way he's right he's like this is what I
don't have female friends like girls
like scheana and Charlie who are like so
gossiping like whiny like they give
girls a bad name and scheana never said
please don't tell Charlie I said this
yeah what she said was so mean she's
like a really cute Cobra and that she
said it so casually imagine what she
says about Charlie when she does want
someone to keep it a secret and when
she's not on camera yeah people are
pointing out I just want talked about
the timeline of James's sobriety because
we saw he was drinking at pride it is
now mark cards in June prize in June so
six months between June and the end of
the year and then we're in March is
three months I think maybe it's a
probably a little less than I'm about
eight and a half yeah but um I don't
even have to stop drinking now like this
if we said the rest of the season
racquel conversation was the beginning
yeah then that really is nine months and
that adds up perfectly he's like going
on nine months maybe there's a few days
missing but I'm gonna just give him the
benefit of the doubt yeah until he
proves me otherwise we'll see him at the
Reunion and I'm sure if he's been
drinking someone will call him out
totally we have deer toasters but is
there anything else that we wanted to
recap um no not in a flop her usual I
loved her right choice and like I
totally heard what she was saying there
but like she shouldn't wear that dress
and she's like unzipped her dress and
you saw her underwear and like she wears
some no Spanx with her dress like what's
that like you take my dress off it's
literally like a circus under there like
wires bras girls Spanx like I just she
doesn't take her dress off and there was
just underwear I can not even a bra yeah
we didn't get any Randall
now that I've seen him once like I need
him in every episode I need their own
show for real like life you're right of
Lala for real they have a podcast now
which is great but so much of what I
love about Lau is seeking her honest a
podcast is a hop skip and a jump to a
reality show yeah so I hope that's where
we're headed and good things are coming
for us okay so we're gonna do tear
toasters which is our advise segment if
you ever want to email us please do so
dear toasters at gmail.com and I think
very appropriately the dear toaster
segment is brought to you by first leaf
convenience is everything now and we
love having whatever we want delivered
right to our door on our time and wine
is no exception if you want to discover
new wine without the work try it firstly
I've been really into wine lately
actually two glasses of wine last night
I it was never really my liquor of
choice but to me there's something so
relaxing about wine and it's like a nice
middle ground for me and I've been
loving it and now having a subscription
to first leaf is coming really really in
handy first leaf removes the hassles and
guesswork of buying wine by expertly
selecting wines based on your unique
preferences what's not to love about
coming home to a personalized box of
wine the cool part is that first leaf
uses your ratings and feedback to refine
each shipment you can also choose what
types of wine you get let's say you're
throwing a party and you want more red
blends first leaf will let you modify
future shipments they add their wine
they add wine to their inventory every
month so you'll always have something
fun and different to look forward to
unboxing is half the fun because it's a
surprise in your house subscriptions are
very flexible you can choose when and
how often you get shipments if you're
having a party I know for my New Year's
party I doubled up you can really modify
it's like it fits your life which is
super nice um and they have a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee which is
also nice so if you receive a bottle
that you're not into which is possible
first leaf will cover the cost
sign up Cheng gets six bottles of wine
for only $29.95 that's literally how
much my glass of wine was at this fancy
restaurant last night plus you can get
free shipping just go to try first leaf
dot-com slash toasts that six bottles of
wine for only $29.95 plus free shipping
at try first leaf le AF com slash toast
okay we're ready for toasters yes I hope
they're perfect to be sponsor okay
firstly yeah because sometimes these
probably they just need a drink
yeah that's half the solution reminder
dear toaster is at gmail.com hopefully
we but we don't read them before we like
to be surprised so we just have them
printed
so let's see I've been dating tear
toasters I've been dating my boyfriend
almost two and a half years now and our
relationship has been very different
since graduating we live about an hour
and a half away from each other and can
really only see each other on the
weekends now that we're not in college I
eat dinner at his house with his family
a lot more than I ever did before
and even though he raved about his mom's
cooking when we were at school I simply
don't agree I've gotten food poisoning
multiple times when at his house after
leaving his house and it is so
uncomfortable the last time it happened
she made me sort of salmon that was
stuffed with seasoned crab meat at least
that's what I think it was I genuinely
don't know and I obviously ate it all to
be polite she was bringing out dessert
my stomach was growling noticeably and I
scarf down chocolate mousse while
feeling like I was going to barf
following dinner his whole family sits
down in the living room which is
directly next to the bathroom
my stomach was absolutely killing me and
I needed some privacy here so I asked my
boyfriend if I could go upstairs and use
the bathroom it was not pretty I will
leave it at that
I told him I wasn't feeling well and
blamed it on the food we had for lunch
even though it's clearly from the
bizarre seafood concoction as mentioned
before we live about an hour and a half
from each other so I had to drive all
this way sorry for being gross here with
explosive diarrhea and I just not
multiples I'm in the Bronx to use the
bathroom at McDonald's Starbucks Dunkin
you name it I actually thought I was
gonna die both from the stomach pain and
potentially getting stabbed in those
sketchy neighborhoods finally I made it
home it's still alive but barely I know
you guys talk about your stomach
problems from time to time on the toast
so I figured this was a good place to
come for help what do I do
should I just never eat there again I
really like my boyfriend I want his
family like me too sincerely a girl but
the runs in the McDonald's bathroom in
the Bronx okay this is not that
complicated
no it's solvable it's very salable I do
think it was this specific seafood
concoction I think now going forward
like you should come to dinner full yep
and then you know don't be rude like
have a little salad but definitely don't
go for the mystery meat no there's there
is an art to pretending you're liking
what you're eating it's having your food
around don't take such big portions
definitely eat before cuz I'm the type
of person even if I'm like not into
what's in front of me if I'm starving
I'll eat it yeah so make sure you like
scarf something down before there's an
art here you don't have to sacrifice
time with your boyfriend or with their
family and you could still really like
them sometimes it's like a familial
thing like her food actually might not
be very good but they're like used to it
already yeah or like sometimes really
good food like my friend Elise his mom
is the most amazing cook but they're
Moroccan and use spices that I don't
really eat a lot and so when I was in
high school going there my stomach
always used to get upset with the
food was so good like I would keep
eating it now I think I built up an
immunity yeah and I'm sure they all have
in this family yeah oh you can either
work on that immunity or just come over
full and eat the food setter you know
maybe from the store and I mean any rice
fan say like yeah there's so many safe
foods like the crab meat concoction it's
not the thing to go for it and don't
just be nice and put your stomach at
risk and eating the whole thing because
you could have really liked it and still
not finished it yeah and also you can
always use an excuse of like you know
you're doing whole 30 you're doing keto
you're doing a vegan like your face
anything that you're trying to avoid
eating there's a diet for it so just
throw it out but that trip of you going
home having to stop it's like actually
my worst nightmare totally in our family
we call it a stress nightmare is having
to go upstairs that like my in-laws and
yeah have diarrhea and like I would just
be so worried I'm gonna clog the toilet
so I have anxiety and iron and then they
would flush multiple times because you
don't want them to like you don't want
to flush the toilet but then you're
concerned can they hear how many times
I'm flushing yeah oh well that's
horrible girlfriend I really feel like
I'm actually I did call it was I was a
faulty toilet because it what I did in
there wasn't even that damaging and I
clogged it at my in-laws house and it
was [ __ ] horrible carring horrible oh
my god I didn't know that plunger like
but not but no one can see me looking
for a bunch of her let me text me bed
like a the plunger I got the watch are
you looking at YouTube videos how to
plunge a toilet okay knowing how to
plunge a toilet much like knowing how to
change a tire is one of the most useful
skills I have to plunge my toilet all
the time because I live with Bend like
it's such an important skill that you
should know how to do yeah and I just
want to say to this day I don't think
anyone until now knows that I had done
that also bathrooms I got away with it
bathrooms especially guest bathrooms
that don't have plungers like under the
sink criminal yeah like to your guests
like further piece of there should be a
plunger in every bath and that should be
a law kind of how you have to have a
window in every bedroom like even in a
basement if yeah we considered a bedroom
you should have a puncher in every
toilet that should be like a zoning law
agree okay next up dear Claudia and
Jackie I recently moved to a new state
and needed a new dentist I don't have
dental insurance so I found an office
that was pretty well priced I went to my
appointment I literally had the best
dental experience I've ever had
here's my issue though in the little bag
of goodies with the mini toothpaste
there was a pamphlet the pamphlet was oh
the pamphlet was
for the Church of Scientology I
personally do not belong to Scientology
nor so I want to get so sorry I
personally do not support Scientology so
I do not want to give my money to a
business supported by Scientology I
don't know what if I don't know if this
is just the dentist personal beliefs and
not like a Scientology run office also I
really love this dentist's office and
it's so affordable do I stay with
literally the best dentists that could
potentially be as a Scientology linked
business additional information I will
be in the state for three more years so
three annual cleanings and I will likely
not have dental insurance for that
entire period love you both and the
toast okay I'm sure to me like having
finding a good dentist that you like
loved I mean who even loves their
dentist that overwrites like everything
uh maybe it was someone else's pamphlet
you know I think if it was part of like
the Sea Org me it would be more
established I just think it's not that
big of a deal just make sure you don't
find yourself like joining accidentally
Scientology yeah I don't think like
you're then you want to be able to
listen to the show anymore not really
sad I don't think those like three
cleanings you're gonna have I really
gonna like make a difference in the
pockets of Scientology and to be honest
I don't
I think Scientology has so much money
they don't need like dentist's office in
random cities like to keep themselves
afloat so it either was just like the
dentist being a freak and like trying to
proselytize or an accidentally maybe one
of the nurses slipped it in or they have
some connection but I think you could
survive it's not a big deal and is that
often like once a year annual cleanings
like that's a lot of annual clean no
three years and annual cleaning every
year that's fine yeah it's like 40
minutes of your life where you just have
to not be coming like a hundred dollars
for cleaning you think yeah and to enjoy
your cleaning like sounds fabulous
yeah fabulous I wouldn't don't don't
sacrifice like as something good just
like for your effort and because there
was a pamphlet in the bathroom yeah it
doesn't say enough on the bathroom in
the bag of goodies that they give out oh
that's [ __ ] weird so yeah that changes
it oh that definitely changes it but
just just try not to get lubed into
Scientology you know as like a good head
on your shoulders like and you can't be
persuaded yeah and if you listen to the
choice you obviously do have a good head
on your shoulders and you probably can't
be persuaded yeah and maybe like make it
a buddy thing going to the dentist oh
yeah in that way you're not just like
alone the Scientologists and then a
Scientologist yourself okay our third
and final tear toasters Deere toasters I
am truly at a loss and desperate for
some advice for my favorites teens
best friend is ruining a family and I
don't know what to do my best friend
let's call her Lisa has been dating this
guy who was married with four kids the
young has just turned one and the oldest
is eight years old
he tells Li said that he's going to
leave his wife er I've 10 years to be
with her but I know in my gut that he's
not they had been dating for a year and
he has been saying he was going to leave
his wife since before they even started
dating one of my other friends knows the
guy and says him and the wife are still
happy together and act like they're in
love when we tell these to this she
doesn't believe us and make some excuses
for him she truly believes whatever he
tells her she is still so young and I
want her to be happy and date other
people because I know she was wasting
her time also I obviously think it's
disgusting that she's okay with doing
this especially because the same thing
happened with my parents and she knows
that it's really affecting our
friendship some days I can't even talk
to her I truly don't know what to do do
I ignore it all and let her ruin a
family and wait she has her life should
I snitch on her to his wife help okay
definitely don't snitch on the wife
because it's not your business but like
especially since you've like been
through this with your parents I think
what this girl's doing is disgusting and
like the fact that no one can get
through it or her she's beyond your help
I would just back the [ __ ] away like you
don't ignore it like you don't say
anything but just like you obviously
can't be friend to someone like this was
so first I was so dumb and who has no
values yeah and if it's upsetting you
like on a personal level you don't need
that sort of negativity in your life
life is hard enough as it is without
having friends who like trigger you with
their actions
yeah like girls who are like he's gonna
leave his wife like oh there that's the
except guys who actually leave are the
exception not the rule so like they're
never gonna leave they have kids like
leave them alone she's obviously so dumb
and you just don't need that and you
seem like you have a good head on your
shoulders cuz you listen in right into
Deer toasters and if you've liked spoken
to her about this before and she doesn't
heed your advice at a certain point you
can't help someone if they're not
willing to help themselves so this might
be like a situation where she needs to
hit rock bottom on her own in order to
understand what's really going on and
maybe just for a while you take yourself
out of the equation and just explain to
her like listen I don't agree with what
you're doing for their family for
yourself also for myself and for those
reasons I'm out on this friendship I'm
pressing pause until you start until you
change your ways sometimes tough love is
so necessary in a situation like this
you need someone to like spiral out like
get dumped and ordered for them to
realize like oh maybe I should have
listened to my good friend who wrote
into your toasters yeah who cared so
much right and tried to help me and I
was so blinded by my own idiocy yeah and
I feel like this is the situation like
maybe other people have found yes in
whether you're the friend
or you're the other woman and it's just
never spot you want to be in ever I feel
like this advice could be heated by
anyone especially like a one-year-old
not that it's like so related to this
but in Margaret Rosoff new podcast she
talks a lot about how she met you up in
take know and it was at the time that
she was married to Jan and the timeline
is really interesting it really explains
and they talk about it a lot on the show
I don't feel like she's ever really
gotten in depth with it um and she does
on this first podcast episode which is
now available on Spotify and iTunes it's
called caviar dreams tunafish budget
with Margaret Cho sits you could just
search Margaret Joseph's find it listen
to me give us feedback we'd love to hear
what you guys think follow at Joe's news
network because there's also a new
episode of mood with or and Elizabeth
today yesterday we got a new episode of
this snatchler Monday we got a new
episode of date night with Raven and
Adam tomorrow we have a new episode of
redheads buzz Club we were just like
churning out content like it's our job
oh wait because it is all day every day
thank you so much for listening to the
morning Tosa money on morning show we
hope you enjoy our interview with
Cameron and Lauren we love them so much
please follow us on instagram at the
morning toast we're almost at 200,000
followers thank you so much listening to
the morning shows Monday morning show we
go live Monday to Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube star watching us
and you didn't please Sophie to
subscribe this video a thumbs up please
also leave a comment you know whatever
you want
also available as a podcast and r-pod
cats we found that Spotify iTunes is
your public video I already to catch max
oh the police it's whoever you choose to
listen to podcasts find us the morning
toast hide maybe subscribe leave a
five-star review about a beautiful
stunning and smart wait I will ever go
so much we're back tomorrow with the
lady gang bye I'm excited bye